that's been able to do the split oh man that's
the toenail save still got [Music] it in front for
Larson Demco diving out just scrawled forward to
make the save and keep it a one-goal game Larson
on Larson there's Larson what a save by Demco
Sensational stop by Thatcher Demco hiset Here
Comes Thor with Maro deor Maro shoots what
a stop and the L stages Primo never say TI
gets across and a big save what a pass to Maro
and a better save by Primo pack it inside they
get it Down Low cross ice pass what a save by
Gibson Great Stop moment to go by John Gibson
on ver no way the goalie is going to be able to
get across Gibson able to do it with the right
leg sneaky shot put on rebound and that's hammered
over the net by Smith did Shay get a piece of that
on that gaping cage skating ability required
and then desperation going stick on Puck you
won't see a much better play than this oh he
smatched that total up to seven points weird
car oh what a stop unbelievable as dorak Rob by
Aiden Hill Christian dvorak's trying to figure
out how that puck did not go in the net unreal
from Eden Hill to recover Monahan Zips it out
High maton looking back door H there the stop on
Suzuki and the golden knights hang on and pulling
out in Montreal there's a play behind the net to
Suzuki and the left arm of Aiden Hill as he comes
across [Music] wow into the slot redirected and
then the shot oh dry shidle with a chance but rosi
came over bounce Pucket turnaround pass their dry
Sidle and wow Sergey boski gets the arm on on it
look how he attacks through now Ryan pulock has a
chance sends one across dco with the right P what
a save off wallstr who then put the rebound off
the outside of the post but Demco was some early
thevery to keep this game scoreless get that first
regulation loss and all a save by Demco he Inon
for his own error he got caught behind the net
fired on goal by Paul N and Dem came scrambling
back to make a marvelous save behind the defense
in glove safe and then a p save on the rebound
by stolar oh my Anthony star's desperation lunged
with that left pad Ryan stres in alone good stop
on the initial say better one on the rebound watch
him lunge with that left toe and just get a little
piece of it Robertson back across the Rony works
it the back hand shot oh stop by flurry Mark Andre
flurry sprawls and makes the stop oh man that's
the toenail save Mark Andre blurry still got
it is Carolina trying to change the score right
now out in front to AO Second Chance jar just
robs him say jari not once but twice ridiculous
stops from Tristan jari H you kidding me there's
the first one and the second one boom and then
the that stretch save after getting dinged up
there in the second turnover here at top of the
crease and Jarvis's shot would not go Tristan jari
did you stop it what looked like he did stop
it and never give up said Tristan jar as he
reached back with the paddle and right there gets
a piece of it gets a lot of it wow what a save by
jar in constant motion bu on a try glove stop
by by yonas Johanson somebody had to grab the
play and it ended up being the goal tender
takes a look puts it in there loose PT shot
Sav by Swan from the seat of his pants takes one
away from Hegel that's been able to do the splits
momentarily look at that push oh ketov with a big
stop for the closing seconds of the period this
game to be 3-2 right now there could be five
goals in this first period without a couple
of brilliant stop back to the front and stopped
that time by Conor Ingram go go gadget leg Conor
Ingram Banana Splits they they named him after
mcil that shot and stop by hu and the rebound
lifted over the net throwing pucks and bodies all
over heluk to the back door what a brilliant look
off from darene and that is unbelievable
stretching out to keep that out of the
net
for